let me say a few words about north korea
from 1994 to 98 north korea went through
a famine
mass starvation caused primarily by king
jong-il
who at the time was the new leader of
north korea after his father's death in
1994.
somewhere between 600 000
and 3 million people died due to
starvation
from all the stories of famine in
history including
my own family history i've come to
understand
that hunger tortures the human mind
in a way that can break everything we
stand for in north korea
during the 90s famine many were driven
to cannibalism
imagine more than 10 million people
suffering starvation for months
and years always on the brink of death
we don't know the exact numbers of
people who died because the suffering
was done in silence
in darkness very little information in
or out most people had to survive
without electricity
without clean water medical supplies
sanitation
and food the north korean propaganda
machine called this
the arduous march or the march of
suffering
and words such as famine and hunger were
banned because they implied government
failure
and once again now in 2021
kim jong-un the current leader of north
korea is calling for his country to
prepare for another arduous march
or march of suffering another period of
mass starvation
as the country closes its borders
looking
at atrocities of the past decades and
the encroaching atrocity there now
i think about the quiet suffering of
millions of north koreans
i think about the torture of the human
spirit
i think about a north korean child who
could be a scientist
an artist a writer but who instead grows
impossibly thin
without food their bodies slowly rotting
away as their parents watch helplessly
i got emotional in this conversation
with you on me
in part because i remembered my
grandmother who survived caldermore
the famine in ukraine intentionally
created by stalin
where 4 to 10 million people died and
many many more
suffered imagine knowing that if you
don't engage in cannibalism
you will die before your children did
and then
they will be eaten imagine because of
this
deciding to murder and eat your own
children as many people did
imagine the kind of desperation torture
that leads up to a decision like that
i'm not smart enough to know what evil
is
know where to draw the line between good
and evil
but stalin king jong-il kim jong-un
are men who are in the name of power are
willing to make millions of people
of children suffer and die from
starvation
i rarely have hate in my heart but i
hate these men
i hate that such men exist in this world
i hate
that the beauty i love about this life
exists
amidst such unimaginable cruelty
i have been haunted by this conversation
by memories of my grandmother's pain
but i've also been warmed by memories of
her love
love gives me hope hope for the
perseverance of the human spirit
even in the face of evil
you